let's jump to the republican national
convention which begins its business
this morning
convening so delegates can formally
nominate president trump and vice
president mike pence
as the party's candidates for 2020. mr
trump will accept the nomination in a
controversial move
on thursday night from the white house
like the democrats last week the
republican convention will look
different than four years ago
huge crowds cheered president trump at
the 2016 convention in cleveland
this time it's not just the visuals that
have changed as wija zhang reports
some of the key players from that event
will not be standing with the president
i humbly and gratefully
accept your nomination
for the presidency of the united states
with those words donald trump reshaped
the republican party
and promised to change the country too i
alone can fix it the balloons and
confetti
capped off a convention taylor made for
the reality star turned presidential
candidate
complete with dry ice and an awkward air
kiss with his running mate
mike pence congratulations dad we love
you
and he turned the event into a family
affair with four of his children
speaking on the main stage when my
father
says that he will make america great
again he will
deliver while ivanka trump now one of
his closest advisers received
high praise for her poise melania trump
mrs trump was accused of plagiarizing
former first lady michelle obama's 2008
speech from the democratic national
convention
your word is your bond and you do what
you say
your word is your bond that you do what
you say you're going to do
just like in his administration a
colorful cast of characters replaced
standard bears of the gop donald trump
will have your back and it may not
always be politically correct
but when your father is phil roberson
i'm used to that
many of his main players like president
trump's first attorney general jeff
sessions turned from friend it is my
distinct honor and great pleasure
to nominate donald j trump
to foe jeff sessions was a disaster he
was a total disaster
other trump allies later fell into legal
trouble
they're going to see a decisive person
with the human side
former trump campaign chairman paul
manafort was arrested
and pled guilty to crimes linked to the
russia investigation
president trump's former national
security adviser michael flynn was
charged and pled guilty too
lock her up that's right
yes that's right lock her up after
leading lock her up chants about
hillary clinton on the convention floor
if i did a tenth of what she did
i would be in jail today cbs news
political contributor and republican
strategist leslie sanchez
says that defining unpredictability was
in the forecast
even back then it told us everything it
was so prescient
about what was coming it was going to
really
be a very unique experience that nobody
could anticipate that's
what the trump 2016 convention now
looking back
told us that we did not know then but we
know now
what a convention to remember and this
year will likely be unpredictable too
with promises
of big surprises president trump is
expected to make an appearance
every night though we don't know how
much he will participate
we do know he has already blasted
democrats for pre-taping
some of its segments and speeches and he
has stressed that
live performances are way more effective
tony they're definitely way more
fun i think the only safe prediction is
it will be unpredictable we should thank
you very much you're right on that point